if you want to be the best learn from
the best
turn knowledge to your advantage with
these life lessons
never argue with stupid people
they will drag you down to their level
and then beat you with experience
if a man empties his person to his head
no one can take it from him
the two most important days in your life
are the day you are born
and the day you find out why
life is like riding a bicycle
to keep your balance
you must keep moving
we have two lives
and the second begins when we realize we
only have one
write your sad times in sand
write your good times in stone
only two things we'll regret on Deathbed
that we are a little loved and little
traveled
better to remain silent than be thought
of fool than to speak out and remove all
doubt
by failing to prepare
you are preparing to fail
give me six hours to chop down a tree
and I will spend the first four
sharpening the ax
iron rusts from disuse
water loses its Purity from stagnation
even so does inaction SAP a Vigor of the
Mind
talking without thinking it's like
shooting without aiming
how many things would you attempt
if you knew you could not fail
it is a shame for a man to grow old
without seeing the beauty and strength
which his body is capable
life did not intend to make us perfect
whoever is perfect belongs in a museum
many of life's failures are people who
did not realize how close they were to
success when they gave up
I can't give you a Surefire formula for
success
but I can give you a formula for failure
try to please everybody all the time
don't judge each day by the Harvest you
reap
but by the seeds that you plant
wealth is like sea water
the more we drink the thirstier we
become
and the same is true of Fame
half the world is composed of people who
have something to say and can't and the
other half who have nothing to say
and keep on saying it
if someone wants to humiliate you
then you are on the right track
don't tell your friend what your enemy
shouldn't know
the only person with whom you have to
compare ourselves
is that you in the past
and the only person better you should be
this is who you are now
a successful man is one who can lay a
firm foundation with the bricks others
have thrown at him
the best way to find out if you can
trust somebody
trust them
by all means marry
if you get a good wife you'll become
happy
if you get a bad one
you'll become a philosopher
the snake which cannot cast its skin has
to die
as well as the mines which are prevented
from changing their opinions
they cease to be mined
never argue with a fool
onlookers may not be able to tell the
difference
there are 1 000 lessons in defeat
but only one in Victory
do not go where the path may lead
go instead where there is no path and
leave a trail
if you are the smartest person in the
room
then you're in the wrong room
if you tell the truth
you don't have to remember anything
don't cry because it's over
smile because it happened
loyalty to Country always
loyalty to government
when it deserves it
the reason why worry kills more people
than work
is that more people worry than work
knowledge is in power until it is
applied
one day in retrospect
the years of struggle will strike you as
the most beautiful
he who has a why
to live for
can bear almost any how
try not to become a man of success
rather become a man of value
the only real mistake is the one from
which we learn nothing
people who say it cannot be done
should not interrupt those who are doing
it
care about what other people think
and you will always be their prisoner
life is not always a matter of holding
good cards
but sometimes playing a poor hand well
do more
the race is won by the horse that
outstrips its Rivals by a head
a clever person solves a problem
a wise person avoids it
our actions can take us to the skies and
throw us into the deepest Abyss
we are the children of our Deeds
the world breaks everyone
and afterward many are strong at the
broken places
I keep six honest-serving men
they taught me all I knew
their names are what and why and when
and how
and where
and who
if a man knows not to which Port he
sails
no wind is favorable
it is better to light one small candle
than to curse the darkness
no man becomes rich unless he enriches
others
smart people learn from everything and
everyone
average people from their experiences
stupid people already have all the
answers
to live is to suffer
to survive is to find some meaning in
the suffering
the clever are not so much looking for
loneliness as they avoid the fuss
created by fools
it is during our darkest moments that we
must Focus to see the light
life can only be understood backwards
but it must be lived forwards
things may come to those who wait
but only the things left by those who
Hustle
when fate hands you lemons
make lemonade
keep away from people who try to
belittle your ambitions
small people always do that
but the really great make you feel that
you too
can become great
Everyone Falls Down
getting back up is how you learn how to
walk
give a bowl of rice to a man and you
will feed him for a day
teach them how to grow his own rice
and you will save his life
is like a play
it's not the length but the Excellence
of the acting that matters
don't hold on to someone who's leaving
otherwise you won't meet the one who's
coming
courage is what it takes to stand up and
speak
courage is also what it takes to sit
down and listen
the only thing that makes a marriage
unhappy
is not a lack of love
it's a lack of friendship
how much we suffered because of what did
not happen
but could only happen
appear weak when you are strong
and strong when you are weak
that which does not kill us
makes us stronger
those who dare to fail miserably can
achieve greatly
silence is not at all a sign of
callousness
only what is empty on the inside rattles
when you feel discouraged
seek healing in labor
a man can never have too much red wine
too many books
or too much ammunition
success is walking from failure to
failure
with no loss of enthusiasm
the first man gets the oyster
the second man gets the shell
everything that irritates us about
others can lead us to an understanding
of ourselves
believe you can
and you're halfway there
the intelligent person avoids three
things in life
in youth lust
immaturity
arrogance
in old age
greed
eat a live frog first thing in the
morning and nothing worse will happen to
you the rest of the day
luck is when preparation meets
opportunity
people never lie so much as before an
election during a war or after a hunt
I have just three things to teach
simplicity
patience compassion
these three are your greatest treasures
nothing shows a man's character more
than what he laughs at
avoid sex in old age
because at this age it is safer to use
other sources of pleasure
time is a created thing
to say I don't have time is like saying
I don't want to
we are like the herb which flourisheth
most when trampled upon
five things never to share with anyone
your problems your projects your ideas
your mistakes and regrets from the past
your income
always forgive your enemies because
nothing annoys them so much
expect nothing and you'll always be
surprised
sometimes it's good to lose everything
in order to understand what you really
lack
a man is lucky if he is the first love
of a woman
a woman is lucky if she is the last love
of a man
you have power over your mind not
outside events
realize this and you will find strength
do not wish health and wealth but wish
good luck
because on the Titanic everyone was rich
and healthy
and only a few were lucky
the woman who follows the crowd will
usually go no further than the crowd
the woman who walks alone is likely to
find herself in places no one has ever
been before
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over again and expecting different
results
both optimists and pessimists contribute
to society
The Optimist invents the airplane
the pessimist the parachute
you can easily judge the character of a
man by how he treats those who can do
nothing for him
associate yourself with men of good
quality
if you esteem your own reputation for it
is better to be alone than in Bad
Company
you can't wait for inspiration you have
to go after it with a club
most people do not really want freedom
because Freedom involves responsibility
and most people are frightened of
responsibility
nothing in this world is worth having or
worth doing
unless it means effort pain
difficulty